I'm at the Tresemme Pro infusion launch
party hanging out here with celeb
choreographer Paris Goebel Paris let's
Dive Right on into it shall we let's do
it Savage dive in I got it you are a
choreographer and you've worked with
some of the best in the business are you
just having a pinch me moment in life
right now yeah I mean I'm literally
living my dream you're also a creative
director as creative director you get to
look at things like inclusivity when it
comes to your dancers and your models so
how much have you enjoyed breaking down
that barrier in that aspect of this side
of the business oh I love it I well for
me it's like when I do whenever I'm a
part of a project I think you know
what's missing in the world what changes
need to be made or even just like things
that you know affected me when I was a
young girl you know how can I make a
difference now to other young girls so
it's actually a really big part of my
work where do you get the inspiration to
create some of these Dynamic
performances that you put together I
always start with the music and I go
from there but it's really just life
like things that I experience as a woman
things that I feel
you know emotions all of that I just
pull from it and create now Paris is
taking on a whole new kind of challenge
an underwater routine for the USA
olympic artistic swim team her aquatic
moves are part of a new short film fluid
so we teamed up with Paris and tresa may
who gave E.T an exclusive invite to the
lunch party
I've never choreographed underwater you
know it was designed to embrace the
fluid movement of the swimmers here
which was treated by the Tresemme
pro-infusion products you're used to
have in there here in swimming caps so
to have their hair out and free I think
was really fun what was your inspiration
behind this routine what's really
beautiful is women's we express our
South through our hair so I think it
just was really natural for me to be a
part of this project because I expressed
myself through my hair every day and
then putting that into choreography or
hierography should we say Translating
that into water I think was was really
kind of effortless where are you going
next you're gonna take the sky yeah I
mean why not
foreign